you may call your next Witness
I'm for Gwyneth Paltrow's day in court
aware that the testimony you are about
to give in the case now before the court
will be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you God
thank you
she was called unusually by the lawyers
representing a man who says her Reckless
skiing left him with a life-altering
brain injury did you know the rules at
the time of the Collision that if you're
in a collision with someone you need to
give your name and information contact
information because I was hit by Mr
Sanderson and he was at fault I assumed
that Eric who was our ski instructor who
was there at the time who was overseeing
the event he said I'm going to leave all
of your information and he said you
should go ski down because my kids were
waiting for me Terry Sanderson a retired
optometrist listened in court he has a
very different version of events he says
Paltrow who was on a family ski holiday
plowed into him from behind in his words
like Godzilla he sustained four broken
ribs and concussion I was skiing and two
skis came between my skis forcing my
legs apart and then there was a body
pressing against me and there was a very
strange grunting noise so my brain was
trying to make sense of what was
happening I thought
am I is this a practical joke
sanderson's lawyers claimed that Academy
Award winner Gwyneth Paltrow was
distracted by her children who she was
skiing with my daughter was down the
hill my son was to my left so I was
skiing my eyes were not fixated only on
my son when Mr Sanderson skied directly
into my back Paltrow will continue to
testify on Monday her husband Brad
falchuk and children apple and Moses are
also listed as Witnesses the trial
continues